et faut-il relancer la réforme des
retraites on en débat avec nos invités
benjamin amar porte-parole cgt 94,1 d'un
renard membre du comité exécutif
d'objectifs france bonsoir à messieurs
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur ft
france pourquoi relancer le débat sur la
réforme des retraites maintenant
benjamin marre enfin il faut le demander
à la macro lee c'est quand même quelque
chose de sidérant
je rappelle qu emmanuel macron nous
avaient dit l'année dernière au moment
de ces grandes messes présidentielle que
il fallait au vu de la pandémie être
capable de tous nous renouveler
moi le premier eh bien écoutez on voit
bien que le monde d'après n'a été
l'objet d'aucune leçon on n'a tiré
aucune leçon est effectivement alors
même que la pauvreté a été explosé selon
un certain nombre d ong
alors même que les ps1 les plans sociaux
justement sont nombreux et vont être de
plus en plus nombreux au fur et à mesure
que les aides publiques vont se mettre
en retrait la seule bonne idée du
gouvernement c'est de remettre sur la
table
cette réforme des retraites qui avait
fait l'objet d'une mobilisation massive
et qui avait été mise en suspens et
parce que justement de l'aveu même du
gouvernement et de la majorité ce
n'était vraiment pas la priorité
et là on se rend compte de quoi et bien
le 1er juillet la réforme scélérate de
l'unedic qui effectivement est une
véritable catastrophe
selon le rapport même de l'unedic
d'ailleurs qui à chaque fois vient
remettre un dollar dans la dans le doubs
boxe de la contestation et bien en plus
on revient avec la petite musique qui
remet la réforme des retraites sur la
table écoutez la bataille des idées nous
l'avions gagner le gouvernement était en
réalité bien aux difficultés malgré tout
ses argumentaires pour nous expliquer
que sa réforme libérale à la fois
conjoncturelles et structurelles était
bonne nous l'avions plier
idéologiquement
maintenant ils remettent ça sur la table
je vais vous dire c'est une majorité de
servir oman et en réalité nous allons
mobiliser justement là-dessus de sel
j'aime d'arona le calendrier ce qu'est
ce que c'est il vous semble hasardeux ou
pas du tout puisqu'on sait que mm macro
a quand même dans le viseur la
présidentielle oui tout à fait le cas
lors il est assez surprenant et même
temps le gouvernement a certainement à
coeur de montrer qu'il souhaite toujours
réformer pour pouvoir dire en 2022
j'ai fêté leurs efforts même si la
réforme est bâclé même si la réforme est
incomplète même si la réforme est
impopulaire sur tous les sujets on se
rend bien compte que le but c'est de
cocher la case j'ai abordé ce sujet et
donc c'est une vision un peu minimaliste
sur un sujet aussi important que la
réforme des retraites alors que je
rappelle que bien évidemment c'était un
sujet passionnel mais le coeur du sujet
des retraites c'est un sujet de mon
graphique c'est pour ça aussi que il
revient aujourd'hui je rappelle que dans
les années 60 on avait quatre actifs
pour un retraité aujourd'hui on a à peu
près à 1,7 actifs pour un retraité
un autre chiffre c'est le corps qui le
dit donc ça peut être suspecté
on a une retraite sur dix aujourd'hui
qui n'est pas financé et à horizon de
dix ans ce sera à peu près une retraite
sur six donc on s'en rend bien compte
que le sujet en fait il est le sujet de
la stabilité de notre système de
retraite faut pas se raconter deux
histoires de bonne aventure c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui avait été totalement
écartée dans la première mouture du
projet on était sur une réforme
systémique fallait tout changer il
fallait réinventer une nouvelle façon de
calculer les retraites
là on revient sur du paramétrique parce
que eh bien les chiffres ne mentent pas
n'y a pas d'argent magique
il faut financer le système des
retraites et à ce titre le débat mérite
d'être posée alors justement pour bruno
le maire sait c'est une priorité cette
réforme des retraites pas seulement pour
lui dans jamais à mars est vrai qu'il va
falloir renflouer les caisses
avec cette crise sanitaire ou penser que
c'est un moyen finalement de d'avancer
doucement ce qui est ce qui nous attend
c'est à dire la fin du fameux quoi qu'il
en coûte 1 d'abord en lien avec votre
question et en même temps avec les
remarques de mon interlocuteur
d'abord faut arrêter simplement
d'arriver sur cet argument de la
démographie on nous l'a ressorti en 2010
au moment de la loi woerth
nous la sortie au moment effectivement
de cette réforme de cette dernière
réforme dite de le voir et là dessus on
a les arguments et on les a battus en
brèche
d'abord il ya des solutions on peut
élargir l'assiette l'égalité par exemple
salariale entre les femmes et les hommes
apporterait des sommes extrêmement
importantes dans les caisses de retraite
on peut élargir aux revenus financiers
on peut effectivement élargir l'assiette
il ya des solutions qui soient autre
autre que celle simplement de dire aux
gens il faut travailler plus longtemps
là dessus s'il faut revenez à nouveau le
départ sans laisser bien vous êtes
d'accord c'est moi juste à tomber
laissez-moi terminée vous me posez une
question laissez moi finir merci voilà
donc en l'occurrence cet argument là on
l'a déjà battue en brèche quand on
rapporte du corps excusez moi nous
revenait moi il y avait eu un rapport du
tort qu'ils étaient extrêmement
optimiste et puis ensuite monsieur
philippe premier ministre à l'époque
avait demandé effectivement que le
rapport se concentre sur une période
particulière chronologiquement ce qui
permettait effectivement de favoriser de
manière biaisée
l'argumentaire du gouvernement donc
là-dessus y compris sur les rapports du
corps les arguments aux lézards et ceux
qui venaient précédemment nous
expliquant que c'était inévitable on
seront à nouveau pour leurs frais sol et
sur les solutions d à l'instant énumérés
par benjamin à marc gène d'arona votre
avis là-dessus c'est en fait assez
récurrent de dire que pour régler un
problème en france il faudrait les
trouver des milliards ailleurs alors
parfois il faudrait taxer les
multinationales parfois les plus riches
si cet argument tenais je rappelle que
la france est le pays dans le lot c'est
2 où on prélève le plus dire que on n'a
pas un problème d'argent aujourd'hui on
prélève massivement en face et ben en
fait on aurait pas de déficit du système
des retraites c'est en fait ce que
monsieur préconise c'est ce qui est fait
en fait depuis depuis 30 ans alors on
pourrait aller toujours plus loin est
taxé et toujours plus la question c'est
quelle est l'utilisation qu'on fait de
cet argent
et c'est là on voit que ça pêche puisque
les services publics tombe en ruine etc
on s'en rend bien compte que sur ce
sujet des retraites bat on a un déficit
on a un trou dans la raquette
il faut pas encore une fois se raconter
l'histoire aujourd'hui le système
il est par répartition des actifs
ans des retraités donc c'est une
équation qu'il faut résoudre et et pour
arriver pour résoudre l'équation de la
réforme des retraites il ya trois
solutions n'a pas d'ennemis bien à 3
soit en effet vous augmenter les
cotisations c'est à dire vous augmenter
les cotisations qui sont déjà record en
france sur les sur les travailleurs soit
vous baisser les pensions
ça peut être un choix qui se défend ce
n'est pas mon option soit vous augmenter
la durée légale de travail et de temps
qu'on passe au travail pour clients
c'est encore une fois le système des
retraites et avec rafik smati
injustement justement barja maamar ce
sont les pistes qui sont justement à
l'ordre du jour allonger la durée de
cotisation à 43 ans mettre fin aux
régimes spéciaux relever l'âge légal de
départ en retraite à 64 ans et 62 ans
actuellement et ce sont les pistes sont
évoquées dans le journal les échos par
le secrétaire d'état aux retraites mais
jamal
c'est une question oui oui je sais je
vous demandais comment placer istar
pluie mais bienvenu long mais que
voulez-vous y compris ce que dit
monsieur qui d'ailleurs confond tout il
nous parle de taxation alors qu'il
s'agit de cotisation les cotisations
monsieur sam sont il ne s'agit pas d'un
impôt ne confondez pas impôts et
cotisations et effectivement je vous ai
écoutés c'est les libéraux nous propose
sans cesse les mêmes solutions qui en
réalité sont le rocher de sisyphe c'est
à dire que à chaque fois la fin ça se
solde par des régressions j'ai à vous
dire les choses sont simples en 1945 on
pouvait financer un système de retraite
généreux alors que la france et l'europe
était en ruines et monsieur nous ressort
la petite musique de la démographie
alors qu'il ya quelque chose qu'ils
oublient un petit peu c'est l'explosion
des gains de productivité c'est à dire
que la main d'oeuvre en 1945 elle était
certes plus nombreuses mais elle produit
elle était beaucoup moins productives et
justement on a des solutions alors
monsieur bien évidemment ne veut pas en
entendre parler
parce que soi-disant en france nous
taxent aurions plus que le soviet de
petrograd mais c'est rigolo
il s'agit effectivement je les dis
pourquoi est ce qu'on ne pourrait pas
effectivement prendre
compte soumettre à cotisations les
revenus financiers pourquoi ce serait
impossible
pourquoi est ce qu'on ne pourrait pas
soumettre à cotisations l'argent maria
en impôts il ya un impôt mondial sur les
multinationales il ya un impôt mondial
sont les multinationales lac a été actée
par les 27
un gène d'arona oui tout à fait mais
encore une fois ce n'est pas moi qui est
déporté le débat sur la taxation c'est
vous qui proposait à chaque fois d'aller
taxer autre chose alors qu'en effet le
débat et les cotisations sont
aujourd'hui record si on revient
d'ailleurs je reprends votre exemple de
1945 de mémoire en 1940 45 l'âge légal
de départ à la retraite
il était de combien il était de 65 ans
alors voici un exemple historique
on va pas comparer la situation
d'aujourd'hui avec la super finale
tandis que bien sûr il ya eu un progrès
social
moi je vous dis juste qu'en 1945 l'âge
légal était à 65 ans pandémie aussi à
prendre en compte
ah oui mais alors ça c'est intéressant
parce que s'il s'agit de faire
comprendre aujourd'hui aux français que
le quoi qu'il en coûte
c'est à dire un plan de relance qui a
très majoritairement pour profiter à
l'offre je rappelle que carrefour par
exemple a mis 4 22% de ses salariés en
activité partielle alors que carrefour
est une entreprise qui a fait des
bénéfices records en 2020 si on explique
que le plan de relance aujourd'hui ce
sont les privés d'emploi et les
retraites qui vont en payer le prix
ne vous étonnez pas si la colère sociale
va continuer à exploser
parce que si l'horizon que l'on propose
à l'issue de la pandémie
c'est une réforme scélérate des
retraites eh bien écoutez
n'allez pas vous étonner si au printemps
ou à l'automne on a une explosion
sociale
après on pourra venir avec des larmes de
crocodile mais les arguments
effectivement d'apothicaire et de
comment dire de vautours
tous exigent toujours plus effectivement
de sacrifices sur le dos des retraites
est bien auront fait leur effet et
effectivement on aura jeté un jerrican
de kérosène sur la colère sociale
un tir a très bien on sera étonné eugène
jeunes d'arona pour revenir à emmanuelle
b
puisqu'il a relancé le débat sur la
retraite lors de son déplacement dans le
lot il promet des décisions difficiles
mais assure tout de même que ce projet
ne ressemblera pas à celui qui a
fortement divisé les français jusqu'ici
que faut-il comprendre selon si vous me
demandez de comprendre quelque chose à
ce qu'a dit manuel matheron est ce que
dit globalement ce gouvernement depuis
des années sur n'importe quel sujet et
notamment les sujets économiques jarre
du mal à vous répondre
en fait le dernier projet il était flou
c'est pour ça que le moment pour faire
cette réforme c'était avant le coc vide
mais le projet était tellement flou est
tellement peu précis on est parti sur
une réforme que eux jugent trop
ambitieuse mais qui en réalité n'était
pas du tout retravailler
on est dans le flou le plus total et moi
je pense qu'il faut dire la vérité aux
français sur l'ensemble des sujets mais
sur ce sujet des retraites c'est pour ça
que je met en regard les éléments
financiers les actifs qui financent les
retraités
ça c'est le premier point le deuxième
point je rejoins monsieur quand même sur
le besoin d'exemplarité sterk envoyer le
message aux français qu'il faudrait
encore faire des efforts je pense que
c'est assez assez peu assez peu
pertinente dans la mesure où si on
demanda à faire plus d'efforts parce que
encore une fois je pense que c'est
justifié ce sur ce sujet il faut que
l'état montre l'exemple et depuis
l'élection des bagnoles matheron aucun
exemple a été menée la dépense publique
augmente de plus en plus on avait des
comités théodule dans tous les sens
ddd projet des grenelle qui se montrent
encore une fois dans tous les sens
encore sur la justice ces derniers jours
donc il faut que l'état soit exemplaire
il faut que l'état fasse les efforts en
premier pour être en capacité qu'une
plein de demandes et je dirais pas qu en
effet il va y avoir des efforts a
demandé mais en est-ce c'est un sujet de
solidarité nationale les retraites et en
tant que jeune je vous le dis et si on
doit travailler plus pour financer les
retraites les retraites de nos aînés
encore une fois je suis prêt à prendre
ma part benjamin avare en une minute
sera le déplacement des macros dans le
lot
lorsqu'il dit que finalement on va quand
même changé un peu notre fusil d'épaulé
ce sera pas tout à fait le
même réforme qu'auparavant est ce que
c'est encore et toujours la politique du
en même temps ou parce que d'une
certaine façon
finalement il reconnaît le fiasco de
2019 alors d'abord sur le et en même
temps comme j'ai eu souvent l'occasion
de le dire il faut arrêter de dire qu
emmanuel macron à une jambe gauche et
une jambe droite emmanuel macron c'est
capitaine crochet il a une jambe droite
et elle est hypertrophié et la jambe
gauche avait en bois donc ça s'est il
faut arrêter avec cette histoire c'est
une mascarade
c'est une une affabulation qui date
depuis 2010 est pour je pense qu'il sait
très bien que le sa réforme de 2019 a
été un fiasco politique qui a été menée
n'importe comment au delà effectivement
deux du fond de la réforme qui était
littéralement scélérat mais je pense que
pour le courrier monsieur a été d'accord
avec moi sur un point bon j'ai pas bien
compris le caire en revanche moi je suis
d'accord avec lui sur un point emmanuel
macron veut faire croire jusqu'au bout
qu'il est un réformiste en des voix à
riom le mot réforme parce que réforme ce
n'est pas régression
merci à vous à jean benjamin amara porte
parole cgt 94 eur gêne à darna membre du
comité exécutif d'objectifs france